[Applause]
uh hey everyone
my name is phil rainery i have worked
across the
tech and art and entertainment
industries for about 10 years now
people typically refer to me as a
creative technologist
i specialize a lot in ar vr interaction
design
and specifically i've done quite a bit
of projection mapping which is what this
talk will be
about i'm now with a company called
lightform which
makes hardware and software for
projection mapping we call it projected
ar
and i will explain a little bit about
that in a minute
so just going to do a quick background
on myself
i got started at a company called
obscura digital in san francisco
they happened to move in across the
street from me and i just
walked in the front door and asked for
an internship one day
they kind of introduced me to this world
of large-scale immersive entertainment
while i was there i worked on projects
ranging from the youtube symphony
orchestra where we mapped the sydney
opera house
and the guggenheim in new york
i later went on to tour with skrillex
and a few other musicians so
i designed his first major production in
2011. it was kind of this
motion capture enabled projection mapped
set piece
that uh you know was kind of
akin to the m on tobin isam show that
was touring around the same time we
actually worked with a lot of the same
folks on that
and also did a fair amount of festival
installations including one at coachella
and a couple for the musician flying
lotus
and in 2013 i went to work for bottom
dolly
this is a shot from the short film box
where i did the projection mapping and
lighting design
and before i talk about box um i
just want to get this out of the way
because i think this is becoming a bit
of a meme
uh so g monk is actually my housemate
and i promise this is not some sort of
like
fitc nepotism why i'm here but he did
convince
uh sean to come to my talk at south by
southwest
so i have to thank bradley for that and
uh
next year if you'd like i'll do a whole
talk about what it's like being his
roommate
oh yeah he wants to let you know that
he's currently in a fog box
shooting lasers so he's being bradley
so projection mapping i don't
particularly love this term because it's
a verb that refers to
a specific action within projection
the actual like physical manual mapping
of pixels to a real object
oop this is what happens when you
build your slides two minutes before the
presentation
okay uh anyway uh that's a slide that
basically depicts
you know actual warping of vertices
around so when you
start projection mapping you start with
something like this basically a black
screen oh you can see it now
so uh when you're actually creating
content you're going around and you're
kind of taking your video assets and
you're mapping them manually to
the world and you know it doesn't really
describe the final output which is the
experience that you create
also when you hear the term projection
mapping you tend to think of these
big budget experiences like box and
these kind of
expensive brand activations these
trump louis force perspective you know
making buildings crumble
and then on the other end you might
think of a typical kind of low poly
faceted stage design that you might see
it like a warehouse party or
at burning man and kind of between these
two extremes
there isn't really anything that exists
outside of the entertainment industry
the the tools and the technology kind of
promote this the software has a
relatively steep learning curve
the hardware is still quite expensive
and
there isn't really something out there
yet that would enable this to exist in a
more
common scenario so
that's really what we're about at light
form and we use projected ar
to describe a form of projection that
is more automated so the user would
actually spend less time doing
mapping and more time actually creating
content
we use computer vision to enable this
and i'll talk about that in a little bit
we're globally aiming to democratize
this medium to
bring the price down to make it more
accessible to designers of every type
not just your creative technologists and
motion designers
but we still do want to maintain a
little bit of that concert and like
theme park magic
so before i get into projected ar i'm
going to talk a little bit about
our mortal enemy screens but
this is a different kind of screen this
is the electric objects e01
a product i backed on kickstarter in
2014
that promised to bring digital art into
everyone's living rooms
uh show of hands who here backed this or
owned one of these
at some point okay like a few
early adopters uh so
the product despite appearing to be just
computer rotated 90 degrees
had some really incredible ideas behind
it
there's this enormous amount of digital
video and interactive art on the
internet but
it currently only exists within our
phones or laptops
there it lives between dozens of browser
tabs hundreds of notifications and other
apps
and it's usually a passive experience
where we view and sometimes comment but
it doesn't provide as much value beyond
the split second we scroll past it
but electric objects they were trying to
change that
they sought to take this you know
experience that we had in these
very general purpose computing devices
where we could you know get distracted
by a million other things
and then give it its own dedicated
physical embodiment
where it was beautiful enough to hang on
your wall you
couldn't get a text message or you
couldn't get an email while you were
looking at the device it basically just
did one thing display digital art
and yes there were plenty of distracting
cat gifs and memes that you didn't
necessarily want
in an endless loop on your wall but
there was this specific excuse me this
specific type of content that i found
particularly interesting
generative content that pulled data from
the internet
this is another digital art display
called framed 2.0
framed could render open frameworks apps
which meant that it could
render more real-time and interactive
content
two examples of this included nicholas
felton's bike cycle which
visualized manhattan's public bike share
program and aaron koblin's flight
patterns which
visualized flight data both of these
data visualization artworks were kind of
stuck representing a single
window of time so there was like a
year's worth of data they would
represent
there wasn't a ui that you could connect
your own data source
but if there were then the art could
basically be personalized
so the artwork could be beautiful but
also functional
because they were connected to the
internet they could provide provide
relevant
real-time information to the viewer for
example
is my loved one's flight delayed or how
far away is my uber or simply
what is the weather forecast
but instead of constantly referencing
our phones for this information where
we have this tendency to get sucked into
other apps and distractions
we can passively obtain this data in a
more ambient fashion
the data is actually built into our
environment this concept of like
media architecture
so as computing miniaturizes we've
started filling our spaces with all
these bluetooth and wi-fi enabled
devices
everything down to our toothbrushes are
now smart
so it seems that physical art and design
objects
are kind of destined to eventually
become a part of this internet of things
internet connected hardware is this this
new medium really that
blurs the lines between decorative and
functional between
artwork and computing interface
this is the nyc train sign a
retro-inspired dot matrix display that
visualizes your local train or bus times
this is an android powered smart beer by
by max braun that simply displays the
weather and news headlines
and when off the mirror would just
return to a normal state
is a patch of sky an led sculpture that
visualizes the weather
and this is vestaboard an internet
connected mechanical split flap display
that
makes those satisfying clicking noises
as it updates kind of like the
grand central station this is
goodnight lamp a pair of internet
connected night lights that sync
together over the internet
so they're able to create a sense of
connection with a far away loved one so
when one light turns on the other one's
on and you know that
someone is awake
so these internet connected devices blur
the line between
design objects and computing interface
yes
you could obtain all of this information
from your smartphone and from social
media
but you didn't have to and while the
information conveyed is fairly limited
that is kind of the entire point
so a trend you may be hearing about a
bit this year
is the concept of calm technology who
here has heard this term thrown around a
bit okay
sorry i'm doing a lot of show of hands
just curious
uh so calm technology describes a form
of technology where the interactions can
exist
in the periphery of our attention not
always requiring 100 of our mental
bandwidth
a good example of this is google home or
voice assistant like alexa
so they're there when you need them and
invisible when you don't
but calm tech can also be dead simple
good examples of this include a
laboratory light on an airplane
or a wall clock they're not distracting
they're not demanding your attention
and you only need to consult them when
necessary
so most objects in our homes kind of
currently exist in the periphery of our
attention they're not you know
beeping at us hopefully too much of the
time demanding our attention
but as they become increasingly
digitized as we start to embed
microchips into every little object that
we own are they going to stay in the
periphery of our attention or are they
going to become you know as distracting
as these devices
jake levine the founder of electric
objects the digital art display that i
first mentioned
he believed that we could maintain you
know
internet connected hardware that is not
distracting
uh he spoke frequently about making
computers that don't demand your
attention a reference to this concept of
calm technology the term com technology
was
originally coined by xerox park
researchers mark weisser
and john celie brown in 1995.
they were both early pioneers of
ubiquitous computing which is a closely
related concept
the concept was further developed by
amber case in her 2016 book by the same
name
this is a great quote from her so i'll
just read it technology shouldn't
require all of our attention
just some of it and only when necessary
uh so i believe that com technology is a
reaction to
our increasing addiction to technology
we have these endlessly distracting news
and social media feeds you have
like you know apple's investors writing
their board of directors saying you need
to do something about
our kids being addicted to their ipads
we now even have products like the light
phone
and anti-technology dumb phone intended
as a temporary stand-in for your
smartphone
but are more devices actually the ironic
solution to
technology overload
all right one more raise your hands i
think i think this is my last one
how many of you find yourselves checking
your phone for one purpose but then get
sucked into
another app yeah okay
everybody yeah i do this all the time
i've like tried to turn most of my
notifications off but i
i kept instagram on and it's just like
it gets me every time
uh i have to read you this amazing quote
from john herman this is an article
titled
how tiny red dots took over your life a
reference to the little
notification badges we see on our apps
dots are deceptively insidiously simple
but they imbue whatever they touch with
a spirit of urgency
reminding us that behind each otherwise
static icon is unfinished business
they don't so much inform us or guide us
as correct us
you're looking there but you should be
looking here they're a lawn that must be
mowed
boils that must be lanced or at least
scabs that itch to be picked
their bubble wrap laid over your entire
digital existence
uh i think that quote is amazing
so all of these objects i just mentioned
while they were conveying simple
information
uh in a in a beautiful elegant way one
of the best things about them
there were no red dots
okay so i want to talk about projection
as a comp technology
projection i believe is an inherently
calm display technology because it can
disappear
it can be used to augment existing
analog objects in subtle ways that don't
distract
and don't overwhelm
this is an example that i created in my
kitchen it's
a marble wall clock that i got from eq3
it's just a
simple analog object but i
added projected light to it that when i
walked in in the morning it would
actually
automatically display my local commute
time so
i was able to actually make a coffee and
i didn't have to take out my phone
unlock it open google maps type in an
address check all of it
i could actually continue doing whatever
i was doing and then just look up at the
wall and see it
there so it was kind of this
contextually relevant information that
was there when i needed it
off when i didn't similarly this is a
laser etched map of san francisco made
by lauren srinivasan
it's just a hunk of cork and plywood
there's
nothing smart or digital about it but it
you know looks nice on my wall
but if i were to hail a lift with my
phone or voice assistant i could
turn it into a illuminated contextually
aware display
so i could just continue tying my shoes
and simply had to look up to see how far
away my lift was
here's a quick video of that demo in
action okay google
get me a ride to trouble coffee
okay your lift will arrive in three
minutes
and yeah you can call me out i made it i
made the destination like all the way
across san francisco so it would be like
visually
appealing but anyway um this is another
fun example
playing poker so you can imagine uh you
know your settlers of catan board being
mapped or any sort of like tabletop game
uh so there's this other relevant trend
that i think is simultaneously going on
and that's the resurgence and popularity
of vintage analog media like books and
vinyl records
a lot of people attribute this backlash
attribute this to a backlash against
digital technology
but david sacks writes that the
resurgence and popularity of vintage
media like polaroid and
books and vinyl isn't necessarily that
we're sick of digital or just feeling
nostalgic
it's that maybe we've just gone too
digital and that we crave more tangible
experiences balanced with the digital
ones
i uh recently bought this vintage
pioneer amp off ebay
and you know the sound is okay it's like
it's nice but really my favorite thing
about it is the
like the satisfaction you get from
flipping the mechanical switches or like
turning
the knob it's like this you know hunk of
metal with like really nice detents
and it's just something that you don't
really get from
a screen or a smartphone after all we
are
physical beings we appreciate tactile
experiences
it's actually pleasurable to hold a nice
book in your hand or take a record out
of its sleeve
so while i believe products like framed
electric objects
are totally on the right track bringing
internet connected
art and information into our lives in a
subtle and
visually appealing way at the end of the
day they are still just screens they're
flat windows into a purely digital world
but the world is not flat as some
conspiracy theorists would have you
believe
the world is not a desktop this phrase
was made popular by mark weisser and
amber case
and i think even more specifically the
world is not a screen made of glass and
injected molded plastic and circuitry
we have a three-dimensional reality with
texture and materials
and physical sensations
so i only half jokingly show this image
of black mirror
comparing it to a warmer more natural
interior
so the image on the left is
obviously a very digital looking scene
whereas the image on the right is
obviously very
you know analog what i argue though is
that
the scene on the right can be equally
technologically advanced and connected
just using a different display
technology so if you were to
turn the digital information in the left
image off you'd be left with just a
bunch of you know black
gaping rectangles whereas the image in
the right you'd be left with
you know the existing architecture and
the existing scene
so projection is this incredibly pliable
medium which can illuminate pretty much
any surface
uh this is an example of uh one of our
generative effects that we're working on
at light form so
the idea being that we can actually scan
and then do edge detection
on you know very complex surfaces and
then immediately map
content back on top of it
projection facilitates tangible
interactions which is a concept
pioneered by
mit professor hiroshi ishii where
digital information is given a physical
form
that you can actually reach out and
touch this is
um i believe it's called materia
material interfaces yeah so this is like
a a
table basically that you know could
morph and change
but they added projection on top of it
and it was facilitated kind of like a
two-way interaction where
you know it could create forms and
shapes and you could then
modify them so light has no volume
instead of needing a hunk of glass and
plastic to render digital content
you can augment existing architecture so
if you're an architect or an interior
designer you can actually just work with
an existing
material palette as opposed to figuring
out where you're going to retrofit
you know a wall to put a screen
so by using projection we are able to
keep our dumb analog surroundings intact
but we can still embed the digital
experiences that we desire
because again it's it's not that we
don't want the digital
it's just that we don't want it at the
expense of the physical
um there's a concept uh called
dumb things smart light which was uh
coined by berg
a research firm in london back in 2011.
they actually also discovered that
projection often looks more interesting
on non-white materials so materials that
have color and texture
this is a picture i saw on instagram
from the airbnb design
team it's from a talk they hosted with
joshua kisi uh
a well-known photographer does anybody
notice
anything interesting about this picture
yeah
uh yeah yeah exactly um and i i don't
know i found this
i found this pretty fascinating actually
there's a perfectly good projector
screen that's hanging up there
but they opted to not use it and
this could totally be because the
projector screen wasn't working or like
it had a stain on it but
what i like to think is that we
you know are so used to seeing our
content rendered on these like perfect
5k
oled retina displays that it's just so
pixel perfect right
there's this novelty to seeing our
content rendered
in the real world where it's like
absorbing the texture and the color
of the surroundings uh you know he's a
he's a professional photographer like
i'm sure he cares very much about how
his content is being rendered but
honestly if you were to pull that screen
down it would just look like this kind
of like white
washed out you know the ambient light
would kill it and so
by just projecting straight onto the
wall it's creating this more
integrated experience
so in order to do a lot of the things i
was describing previously
with you know mapping physical objects
and putting pixels precisely
in the real world you need to introduce
vision
projectors are not cameras they can't
see so
in order to understand where the pixels
are going you need to somehow map them
projected ar becomes a content creation
problem but also a computer vision
problem
and this is why we're building live form
lightform is a camera and an embedded
computer that adds computer vision to
most projectors
it will precisely map where the pixels
fall in the real world letting you
create content directly on top of it
as i mentioned projected ar only exists
in this kind of limited
niche realm of high-end entertainment
and phd research
box cost us almost a million dollars to
create
this image on the right uh is using a
really high-end motion capture system to
do
real-time tracking and this is kind of
the future which i'll talk about in a
little bit of where projected ar is
going
but with light form what we're trying to
do is make the medium more accessible to
a wider range of users
not just most images not just motion
designers or creative technologists like
us but
any designer hobbyist business
uh this is owner collaboration we did
with gemma o'brien where we had her come
and
do a mural in our new office and then we
used some of our tools to create
uh an augmented reality kind of
lit up mural and yes it says it's lit
we're like we're like dying to release
this because we're pretty sure that by
the time we release it it's lit is gonna
be
like i think it's already dead
uh this is a projection menu at a cafe
across the street from our office in san
francisco
so we worked with jeff goodwin a local
designer to
create a three-dimensional sculpture out
of wood and metal
which we then map with digitally
updatable content so
the barista there can just open up our
laptop and
change the menu um immediately there's
no need to like
you know reprint or have somebody come
in and do the chalkboard
the sculpture's materials complement the
design of the space and
the staff you know like i said can
quickly update
so it provides the convenience of having
digital signage
but without looking like digital signage
and this is something that we hear a lot
from potential retail customers where
you know putting up screens for
signage tends to make you feel a lot
like a fast food restaurant
and you'll notice like even starbucks
they don't they don't do it they've got
a system that they're kind of trying to
avoid
the screen aesthetic generally
so lightform works by connecting to
any normal video projector then it
projects light patterns through the
projector which
are detected by our onboard camera this
process
is known as visible structured light and
it relies on
kind of principles similar to stereo
vision to extract depth data
so once we map all of the projector's
pixels we send this scan to our desktop
software
lifeform creator so this means that
content creation no longer starts with a
black screen you're actually authoring
content
on directly uh what the pixel sees or
sorry what the projector sees
uh and then of course with lightform
when you're actually making the content
and you're doing the edits in real time
you're not only seeing it
on your screen as you would with a
normal photo editing tool but you're
also seeing it in the real world
so mapping all the projector's pixels
allows us to do some pretty neat things
such as applying generative content
so here you see the uh the process
actually happening in real life
those are the structured light patterns
and what we're doing is
we're actually reprojecting the image
back onto the scene and so this is
literally with a click of a button you
can do this tron effect we call it
which is a simple edge detection filter
but that contents rendered on the device
so we can you know do simple things like
change the color or change the stroke
width
and it took you know what would have
taken
30 minutes to go through and trace all
those uh outlines
only a few seconds
so thanks to the computer vision plus
generative effects the speed by which we
can create the content
is dramatically increased this is from
a recent renegade projection mapping
trip we did in san francisco
we made this bike which we brought out
and we kind of just
quickly mapped objects around town
these sculptures were by hypeykozo
they're uh
artist duo that brings them out to
burning man and
they were throwing this closing party
for them so we actually showed up
uh used our system to do a scan and then
we can
immediately apply content to it
here's some early shots of some of our
software that's currently in development
and
as you'll notice it looks a lot like a
photo editing tool
so we have that projector scan as the
background image that lets you
directly edit on top of it you can do
kind of
magic wand style quick selection uh very
very easily
and then we also go ahead and like
vectorize that so you're able to then
move and modify the shapes you know this
helps with realignment if your projector
moves
but it also serves as a basis for
creating a lot of the generative content
um this is a scene again kind of
demonstrating
this selection process so just clicking
the bottles
flood fill dragging on stock video and
it's
instantly mapped so instead of having to
go through and actually
you know mask out that kind of complex
form
we can just do it with a with a raster
based selection
so the system consists of our hardware
which is called lf1 and
our desktop software lightform creator
they talk together over wi-fi
and it will work with most projectors
aqua across a wide range of
throw ratios so we don't do any like
active infrared emission it isn't like a
connect or a real sense
so what that affords us is the ability
to have no range limitations so if you
can see it
then lightform can see it
so lightform works with most projectors
it'll work with like you know
cheap 300 pico projectors all the way up
to expensive installation grade
projectors
but let's talk about those for a second
because those are still kind of
a massive pain point for people
how is this future of ubiquitous light
projection that i described previously
actually going to come about
projectors they're big ugly noisy
pretty hard to install they're they're
not fun i i don't know how many of you
have ever tried to install a projector
on a ceiling but it's
kind of a miserable experience
and some of the things that i kind of
neglected to talk about in my previous
slides was
where did i actually put the projector
so these slides will give you an idea of
the links i went to
in order to hide them this one here i
put behind a picture frame but you can
see there's an led projector
an intel nuke and all the power supplies
like there's a power
cable running up the wall all that
this one uh i decided to conceal
inside of a pendant light my uh my
fiance
and and and bradley actually they were
very patient with me and this was
totally
a fire waiting to happen but
it it created it created this uh
pretty cool like phillips hue enabled
projection relief that i had on my wall
so
it would sync with our lights and i
could change the content with this app i
built
this kind of kicked off a series of
reliefs
that we made this is another view of
that one
this one we called proto tile zero this
was a parametrically designed
uh sculpture that was interactive
we were tracing kind of the wireframe on
top of it it was
milled out of a cnc out of a tooling
film
and then we reprojected kind of this
generative content on top of it
and then this was one we did with g monk
this was another parametric
sculpture we debuted this in san
francisco at
an art gallery and it was part of a
larger show that he had
but this was one of the first times we
actually used light form
in the real world to calibrate
projection to
a surface
[Music]
what was cool about that too is that you
know i didn't have to leave my laptop
behind to to run the installation it
would have actually been kind of
difficult in this particular
scenario we just have the lightform
device on top of the projector
and we can just run the content off of
[Music]
that
so you still probably notice projectors
are ugly
they're big and bulky and noisy so how
do we go from projectors that
currently look like this to ones that
look a little more like this like
traditional light fixtures
the answer of course is lasers
and leds
uh in fact we're already seeing
projectors take much more discrete form
factors
these are all led or laser video
projectors
so led and laser light sources they
output far less heat
requiring far less cooling the fans can
be much smaller
quieter the light sources also last 10
times longer
so instead of needing to climb up on a
ladder and replace a bulb every 3000
hours these last
30 000 hours so they can effectively run
their entire lifetime without ever
needing any maintenance
they also produce more saturated colors
and in some instances are focus free
meaning that you don't have to have
optics there that if you're moving the
projector around to focus on different
planes you would have to refocus all the
time but
some of the lasers use coherent light
meaning
yes they will damage your retinas but
they don't have to focus so
that's a plus
also thanks to cheap embedded computing
many of these projectors feature their
own operating systems and media storage
and wi-fi
you know android powered everything
basically
so there's no need to run long hdmi
cables or have additional hardware
so something we know from just kind of
being in the industry is that
projectors as we know them are basically
going to go away
pretty soon the future of the industry
is is definitely in
projected ar and mapping the thing is
projection just can't really keep up
with
oled lcds screens i'd say
you know give it a couple years and this
projector here will probably end up
getting
replaced with an oled screen either the
price will come down so much or fitc
will get so big that you guys will just
have these like
massive 8k displays
and the current kind of cutting edge of
projection mapping
is leaning heavily real time so
generative content
like these so the top two
are from in the ishikawa
wanatabi lab in tokyo so these are using
really high frame rate projectors with
expensive like vicon motion capture
systems they have markers on the actors
faces
the bottom one is a demo from panasonic
they're actually developing their own
sensor which they have embedded you know
into the projector
more or less that does very high frame
rate real-time tracking
the image on the left is a pretty cool
project from harvey moon
he is a technologist in san francisco
used to work at obscura
he's actually using the htc vive
trackers so the little tracking pucks
that you can get from
the vive vr system and those provide a
really
low latency tracking system that's
relatively affordable
uh this also exists though outside of
you know the high-end entertainment and
this is something that's kind of existed
in
phd research for a while
i shared the stage with jared fitlin of
argo design who's been up here a couple
times
and his image in the top left he calls
it interactive light which i love
and it basically you know is the next
kind of wave of
of desktop computing computing that
actually works its way into the
environment
dynamic land is a nonprofit in the bay
area that
they basically turned the entire room
into an interactive display
and you know you can program live on
your table
so oh excuse me
this this is actually a pretty cool one
um so this is a
technology from microvision they make a
sensor they're
based out of the pacific northwest and
what this is showing
is there's actually no difference
between the projector and the sensor
they do a technology called laser beam
scanning so
effectively it's lidar like you would
see on a self-driving car
except the lidar is also projecting
visible light so
it doesn't require any calibration of
optics you basically have
both the sensing and the projecting
happening on the same focal plane
so anyway at this point you know we're
kind of
solving the uh the the industrial design
problems
with laser and light laser and led light
engines we are
solving the lamp replacement problems
and we're solving the computer vision
problems with
light form i'm going to quickly talk
about a few
questions that we typically get asked
with projection mapping
so what about brightness at light form
we've mapped out
the led and laser projector brightness
on this kind of graph so this
demonstrates that
we predict an affordable 3000 lumen
laser projector is not too far off
probably within the next couple years
and 3000 lumens would be more than
sufficient for
your average living room a lot of the
demos i was showing previously were in
the 1200
to 2000 lumen range but what you
we don't actually care about is lumens
what you care about is lux
which is lumens over area so
projectors nowadays are typically
designed to cast the
largest image possible so they're
spreading their light out over a really
large area
this is great for watching you know big
screen movies or
football games but it's not ideal for a
lot of the smaller types of ar content
that we've been showing
so what you can do is take
an equivalently bright projector but
just spread the light out over a smaller
area
or take a dimmer projector that's much
smaller and create a smaller image
and then you've actually got more light
concentrated in
a smaller area which yields the same
amount of lux
another question we get asked frequently
about are shadows
so if you're going to get up close to
the content you're going to be
interacting with it
what about casting shadows and not being
able to see the image
this one is actually pretty easily
remedied by adding
more projectors just like you would add
more lights in your kitchen
so you don't necessarily have to worry
about
blocking the image
so i mentioned you know a few of a few
of the things that we're addressing
the the vision the industrial design the
light sources
at this point really all that needs to
happen is somebody needs to take all of
these things kind of embed them into a
single device that's integrated
and then find a way to install them in
homes and businesses everywhere
it's really just an infrastructure
problem at this point which a lot of
other kind of connected home devices are
are running into the same things but as
more you know housing is built we see
this as being something that could
eventually become
just kind of a de facto default uh
piece of new development
so projection is a column technology it
lets us maintain and celebrate our
analog surroundings
while giving them new digital clothes
and as projected light and
you know these sorts of interfaces
continue to make our way
uh make their way into our homes and
living spaces
we should consider com technology design
principles so
designing them to be not distracting and
not demanding our attention
so i'm going to end on this slide this
is kind of like my
my black mirror screen dystopia slide
except this time
i'm referencing the headset ar future
vision
of hyper reality which was a short film
that kind of depicted this
world in which you're bombarded with
pop-ups and advertisements and
spam and you can't escape it
the image on the right obviously is the
movie her which
is not exactly a utopia but it kind of
depicts this world in which
technology has disappeared it's faded
into the background
other than um his desktop computer and
he has like a really badass
hologram that uh lives in his living
room there aren't really any
screens in the movie they've kind of all
gone the way of this ubiquitous voice
interface
and so what i believe is that with
projected ar
we can achieve a future vision that is a
little bit more
you know like the movie her in the sense
that the technology isn't necessarily
in your face demanding your attention
100 of the time that we have these
ambient displays these kind of
ubiquitous interfaces
that can be there when we want them but
can
disappear when we don't
thanks a lot